bonsoir je suis you et je m'appelle vent
là je vois deux ans et je suis chanteuse
je suis né au portugal
j'ai grandi à coups de tête et j'habite
pas je me suis beaucoup la petite clio
qui était patente
quelle merveilleuse une petite fille et
un garçon tant mieux à moulis aux
allures
après plus d'une heure
m
là c'est un retour à moi je suis désolé
j'avais 20 ans toi lio est ce que tu as
une étiquette pour ta musique
mais les gens vont mettre plat sur le
dos alors alors je suis pas du bubble
gum rock pas n'importe quoi des variétés
non ma principale c'est que le succès
soit avec toi et j'ai invité liot pour
que et coordonne aujourd'hui mais non je
prends mal tombé il faut de tout pour
faire un monde et pour faire de la
télévision
c'est va chanter maintenant serait pas
croire parce qu'il va me comme je dois
commencer sans musique qu'ils ont dû
enregistrer un morceau de ma voix déjà
ça va pas mal pour qu'ils viennent appel
téléphonique au roi maintenant il vous
sauver bon alors on va s'arranger tient
lieu de attention avec les biens des
visites à l'eau ce qui est à l'
paritaire mais toi